[Musique]
benson bonjour merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors la californie
un des premiers états à se confiner
début mars qui se recombinent cinq mois
plus tard
comment le comprendre le premier
confinement n'a pas été suffisamment
respectées ou c'est d'un autre ordre
c'est une très bonne question
la californie connaît une situation très
différente de certains autres états qui
ont également imposé de confinement très
tôt la californie a mis en place un
confinement très strictes très tôt comme
le michigan new york le new jersey
l'illinois également il ya eu des
consignes très strictes
les restaurants les bars ont été fermés
la californie ne permettait même pas à
ses habitants de se rendre sur les
plages
d'autres états comme le texas et la
floride des états très peuplés ont dit
le salon des confiné assez tôt et
recommencer mais la californie n'a
jamais mis un terme à son confinement
comme par exemple texas nous avons vu
une explosion du nombre des cas au texas
et en californie
mais ce sont deux cas différents car la
californie n'a jamais autant relaxé des
consignes que par exemple le texas où la
floride
et pourtant ils ont beaucoup beaucoup de
cas donc ce que vous lui dites c'est
finalement la situation en californie ne
reflète pas la situation aux états unis
oui effectivement c'est une anomalie ce
qui se passe en californie est très
différent que ce qu'on observe dans
d'autres états très peuplées pourrait y
avoir plusieurs raisons à cela le
gouvernement californien ne permettait
pas les déplacements en public
ne permettez pas l'ouverture des
restaurants ou des bars mais la météo
en californie et au texas est très
différente donc certaines personnes
auraient pu décider de ne pas rester
chez elle de sortir d'où cette
augmentation du nombre des cas on n'en
parle pas beaucoup mais il faut savoir
également que même s'il ya une hausse du
nombre de morts quotidien le rapport
entre les nouveaux décès et les nouveaux
cas est bien plus bas qu'ils ne
l'étaient en mars et en avril
donc même si nous avons beaucoup de
nouveaux cas le nombre de décès ne
vendent pas aussi rapidement et il
semble que la raison en soit que les
personnes plus jeunes sont concernés
plutôt par cette seconde vague alors on
en vient à ces images qui ont fait le
tour du monde à donald trump qui est
apparue avec un masque lors d'une visite
dans un hôpital militaire dans la
banlieue de washington
est-ce que selon vous cela marque une
prise de conscience du président
américain notamment dans le sillage de
jaillir ball sauna rocchi à et ester qui
a été testé positif aux colis de 19
c'est une possibilité effectivement les
images ont vu le tour du monde comme
vous le dites donald trump porte un
masque
cela montre donc que les gens entendent
bien réfléchi à ce mass car il est à ses
couleurs
le président et le vice-président porte
maintenant des masques alors que le
président avait beaucoup résisté à cette
cité et il y à beaucoup un débat très
important dans ce pays entre ceux qui
portent le masque et ceux qui ne portent
pas c'est vraiment le point d'ébullition
il ya beaucoup de colère des deux côtés
ici
on ne porte pas un masque les gens sont
en colère si on important les gens sont
également en colère et donald trump
samples décidé de se tourner vers ceux
qui portent des masques mais en tout cas
c'est base électorale est contre donc en
tout cas le fait que donald trump porte
un masque cela a eu un impact finalement
sur les citoyens américains
est ce que le port du mac c'est un peu
plus généralisée je ne sais pas si le
nombre de personnes portant le masque a
augmenté mais dans l'état de michigan
par exemple le gouverneur à instaurer
une nouvelle règle
on ne peut pas forcer les gens à le
porter mais il a exigé que tous les
commerces nécessite le port du masque
pour accueillir des clients
et sinon les commerces crise que de
perdre leur licence d'exercice donc
certains états essaye de rendre
obligatoire le port du masque mais en
géorgie à atlanta par exemple le
gouverneur porte un masque encourage la
population à le faire mais n'a pas émis
de décret pour le rendre obligatoire
donc les différents états en différentes
s'approche et une chose certaine il n'y
a pas de stratégie unique pour le port
du masque
alors on a vu les copies de partie et
cette histoire tragique de la mort d'un
trentenaire au texas et yat-il encore
beaucoup de citoyens américains
sceptiques quant à la réalité de la
gravité du coronavirus ya effectivement
beaucoup de sceptiques aux états unis
ils remettent en question le nombre de
morts ils remettent en question l'idée
que le cours navire ne serait plus
dangereux que la grippe
le problème c'est que les tests sont ne
sont pas bien mené aux états unis
n'ayant pas assez de données sur le
nombre de personnes et qui
honte attraper le corps navires us
qu'elle ait eu des symptômes ou pas donc
nous ne savons pas qui l'a eu et nous
savons pas quelles personnes sont
particulièrement vulnérables
et cela continue et plus cela continue
plus cela génère de scepticisme au sein
de la population
je pense que les gens deviennent de plus
en plus sceptique avec le temps alors
pour conclure la disparité des
politiques sanitaires entre les états
est ce qu il est là le problème majeur
aux états unis
cela fait toujours partie du problème
aux états unis il y à différents points
de vue très divergences états unis
nous avons des équipes il faudrait
l'imaginer comme un tournoi sportif il y
à l'équipe pour le gouvernement où
l'équipe contre le gouvernement l'équipe
un masque l'équipe pas de masque et la
population et se divisent en camps
s'agissant de toutes les questions
police possible car la question est
extrêmement politisée merci beaucoup
benson d'avoir répondu à nos questions
vous rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
d'investigation